[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct before you were anything like
your talent
I remember you wanted to be a pokémon
trainer anyway yeah
yeah that didn't really worked out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me but I've
been so lonely
they tried to talk to me all the time
all they hear is pika pika you can hear
him right guys adorable you're adorable
they can't understand me kitchen no one
else I don't need a Pokemon period then
what about a world-class detective
because if you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
that brought us together and that magic
key is called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah tell us what we want to know pipe
yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop
you're good cop in my head I saw that
differently
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can't take care of myself
when you're 18 give these people a
chance because that's what they're
giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're disabled foster
kid you've got it all if you could have
one superpower what would you think
everybody chooses flight you know why so
they can fly away from this conversation
no cuz heroes fly well you hear your
fake family to stand up for you hey
sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you ask a peon
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
service wait for real okay
Shazam you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this cake
Crusader stuff tonight yeah it's crazy
right
what are your superpowers super powers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay why are you talking
you know I don't think it's gonna buff
out your postcards your phone charge
like a bad guy right
you have full immunity
I'm will prove you're dead sorry about
your window you're welcome for not
getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
everything the light touches
is our kingdom
but a keys time is ruler rises and falls
like the Sun
one day
the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember
[Music]
don't wake up let's go the elephant's
ninos
look at that
I got a baby what is that a face only a
mother could love
sir many of us find you handsome I was
talking about the elephant you have
until tomorrow night to fix that me make
those ears disappear don't look at me
hi baby Jambo welcome to the circus
brought them here no matter how small
yes something very rare
[Music]
you have wonder
[Music]
you have magic come with me
we should saw all that other things
really singing
[Music]
your miracle I wasn't Dumbo
I'll take big deep this is it just like
the rehearsal except the lights music
firing crowds you could do it
quite alone fly
you've got Wow this place is amazing why
the buns gonna meet us here he must be
held up somewhere hey up here Astro Boy
if you think you can take our top prize
spot your room dead wrong help me get
out of here
[Music]
has never been in more danger human
braid is what drove us underground all
those years ago to escape from your
rapacious appetite
because
I warn you boy
[Music]
you are not prepared for the truth
behind what you seek
[Music]
no you will be
- best fair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bring me the land your life begins now
[Music]
Aladin
[Music]
you really don't know who I am Jeannie
wishes land
none of that ringing about we're so good
thanks I am late happy nice thank you
you too
thank you new dress yes it is hot you
know what just happened
[Music]
which passed Britain Peter Parker here
to pick up the passport please
matey's face pack your suit I just want
to go on my trip with my friends Europe
doesn't really need a friendly
neighborhood spy
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no that's nice you
you look pretty too
so nice to finally meet you
spider-man your Nick Fury put some
clothes on let's go for a ride is he
gonna be okay like that might want to
turn him over so he doesn't swallow his
tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker job to do
are you going to step up or not
your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect him sup dickwad
[Music]